I would venture to say that more women
are gonna come out and vote for Donald
Trump in 2020 than 2016 as president
Trump's daughter-in-law Lara launching
his women for Trump coalition in
suburban Philadelphia in July the shore
up support in this crucial group of
voters the president narrowly defeated
Hillary Clinton in Pennsylvania in 2016
by less than 1% but Republicans have
been losing voters in the suburbs so to
keep Pennsylvania red mr. Trump will
need to hold on to an increase support
among women in counties like those in
the Philadelphia suburbs we sat down
with eight women from across the
political spectrum at the gem restaurant
in Norristown a suburb of Philly if
everybody would just go around my name
is Debbie I am a little disillusioned
with politics but I am a Democrat and I
plan on voting my name is Cynthia
I'm an independent and I'm registered as
a Republican my name is Mary Lou and I
will be voting for President Trump in
2020 I'm now Jimenez I'm an independent
and I'm not gonna be voting for Trump
Mary on DiGregorio voted Democrat before
and flipped the switch to trump I'm
Julia I'm a registered Republican I
voted for President Trump not because he
had the best manners but because he was
the most qualified candidate sure al I'm
a Democrat and I have some conservative
ideals Melinda
I've been a registered Republican for a
long time but I switched to the Democrat
Party last year but I don't like to be
labeled as either a Democrat or a
Republican I'm an American voter how
many of you are still persuadable
I'm almost way too well I do not vote
straight party ticket could there be a
Democrat you could vote for anything is
possible could you vote for President
Trump no no could you vote no good you
cannot vote for a Republican sure yes
same here show of hands who thinks the
country is headed in the right direction
what do you like about what's happening
oh I like the fact that you know how my
portfolio looks pretty nice right now I
can make my taxes next year because you
know as time goes by you know cost a
living does not match the cost of you
know really living right Julia your hand
up went up to I would say his
international policy has been bold and
effective in ways that we never
anticipated getting rid of Isis getting
rid of suleimani getting rid of al
baghdadi I mean bold I will tell you
personally I am a Zionist for a
president just so boldly stand for
Israel he's very important to me and I'm
a Christian by the way and finally
national security is critical for me
strong borders so I want address yes
about the border one of the things that
has bothered me is the humanization of
people in the border and how people are
mistreated humanizes so there is a lot
of issues for me there about racial
profiling the issue of the board there
is one that I can forget or forgive I
have to agree with you I think that
Donald Trump is allowing people to make
the decision to mistreat people at the
border to have racially charged marches
because a man has proven to be powerful
and to take a hard stance on something I
like that part of it I do you like that
he's taken hard students you want some
things yes but he's not taking the hard
stance on the racial issues which are
very close to me because I'm a black
female right we need for him to take a
hard line and say hey listen we don't
act like that here what's the issue that
really is gonna determine who you vote
for this year I think the economy is
very important economic fairness is very
important to me I'm not a Bernie Sanders
supporter I'm not an Elizabeth Warren
supporter but I believe that the Tax Act
of 2017 was skewed in favor
of the half of the 1% and the
corporation's who's leaning Democratic
at this point so there's four of you
have you picked the candidate yet no no
I have who have you picked by why
honestly the lesser of the evils right
now he's got past experience I think
it's that's another thing okay Melinda
and definitely voting for a Democrat and
who can best be Trump how important is
that for it's for more Democrats here
definitely yeah
and I do think Biden's probably at the
top of list but I'm still looking at the
other candidates also so one of my
concerns as an independent is that I'm
gonna have to vote certainly not for
Trump but for the less evil of the
Democratic Party or whoever else shows
up so you're just you're disappointed in
your choice I am disappointed I don't
have choices I don't I don't feel that I
have someone who's gonna move me but you
do have the option to do a ride in I did
a ride in in 2016 my family took issue
with me that I was complicit in Trump's
election but it was a matter of
conscience I want somebody I can look up
to somebody who has dignity somebody
that's not bullying I don't see Trump is
bullying though I see him challenging
because the ridiculous that goes on
sometimes that he you're right he's not
a politician I thought it was refreshing
to find a businessman who made himself a
millionaire want to work for me that's
don't you think he's very thin-skinned
my husband's thin-skinned and I
whack-a-doodle and I'm still with them
26 years and I think a politician needs
to be thicker skin and not excoriate
those who disagree with I don't tell you
there's a long okay who have failed
because they've taken the high road and
they've been buried by it and I think
I'm not saying that this necessarily
appeals to me but I think Trump appeals
to a lot of people because
he punches back so Donald Trump isn't
everyone's cup of tea without a doubt
without a doubt I'm going to vote for
him I don't like everything he says I
don't need him to be like me I need to
be safe and I need to be able to know
that my economy for my friends my family
is solid his President Trump going to be
reelected I think you'll be
if your team Trump watching that you're
feeling pretty good don't think those
are my people if you're trying to remove
President Trump you're saying I got some
work to do well for Trump voters at that
table for people who will not vote for
Donald Trump still trying to figure out
who they will vote for yeah that's very
much up in the air a couple people at
the end came up to me and said you know
I'm very intrigued by Bloomberg which
was in fact fascinating he's starting to
pick up steam Anthony well he's
certainly being looked at his strategy
is very different we'll see I don't know
if your team Trump if you're feeling so
good hearing those voters because what
they're saying they're not saying that
he they think he's a good person or
trustworthy or they just think that
certain things are going well and
therefore they're willing to overlook
the things they don't like the character
attorney because you know they're gonna
vote for you even though they're
sometimes they have to hold their nose
and turn the other way they were going
to vote for you yeah they're not saying
that they like them or think yeah good
man though that's interesting but that's
really the election the election is
gonna be fought among voters like that
it really is yeah indeed that was so
interesting smart women at the table
like that too